in 64 games for nintendo switch have
been having some issues a quiet place is
becoming a game and phasma phobia has a
nightmarish new update i'm persia and
this is your gamespot news
nintendo switch online subscribers who
have upgraded to the new higher cost
expansion pack can now play in 64 games
on the go unfortunately some fans are
less than pleased with the service
citing various technical issues and lack
of support for n64 features like the
controller pack the n64 classic the
legend of zelda ocarina of time is sure
to be one of the service's most popular
games but it's clear that something
isn't quite right with the version of
the game nintendo is currently offering
screenshots shared on twitter show the
nintendo switch online version doesn't
look the same compared to previous
versions with differences in draw
distance water textures and fog some of
those differences look like they may
come down to variations between the
japanese and north american versions but
it's clear that the version currently
being offered as part of the service
isn't living up to some fan standards
players have reported latency issues
when attempting to play online in games
like mario kart 64. while some of the
footage being shared on twitter could
come down to poor connections others are
claiming the issues stem from a lockstep
netcode that effectively pauses the game
until other players are all in sync one
of the biggest complaints across the
board is the inability to remap controls
for games on the service you can remap
buttons on a system-wide level that
affects every game but the six buttons
on n64 versus four on switch isn't
something you can really get around
these are just a few of the issues fans
have been experiencing and many are
hoping nintendo will adjust them in
future patches but the company has yet
to announce any official plans
[Music]
paramount's very popular movie series a
quiet place is getting turned into a
video game set for release in 2022 the
game is coming from saber interactive
illogica and epitome it will be an
untold story of survival set in the a
quiet place universe that suggests it
might tell an original story as opposed
to following the events of the film
according to the official description
the game captures the compelling
suspense emotion and drama for which the
series is famous developers who worked
on the rainbow six and far cry
franchises are among those working on
the new game saber interactive which is
owned by embracer will be publishing the
game there is no word yet on platforms
for the a quiet place game nor have we
seen any images or video it is described
as a single player story driven horror
adventure and elagica said in a
statement the a quiet place video game
will let fans experience the tension of
the films with a level of immersion
they've never felt before
in a fitting move for a game that's all
about hunting ghosts phasmaphobia has
released a huge nightmare update just in
time for halloween the new maple lodge
camp site is a medium-sized map that
combines indoor and outdoor areas you'll
be able to explore picnic areas a number
of tents a log cabin and an eerie
haunted lake the developer warns that
the map is one of the most detailed yet
which means outdated computers may see
fps drops when loading up the new map
the new map also adds a new truck
minimap design which the update notes
say will be the standard for future
minimap updates rolling out later on the
other maps four new ghost types have
been added with the new update as well
and players will have a higher chance of
encountering one of those new types for
the duration of the halloween event the
new ghost types are named on rio the
twins obake and raiju i probably
butchered those i'm sorry the update has
also added a new feature in the form of
weather with each new contract now
loading in with a different weather
event in play this can be one of six
different weather events clear skies fog
light rain heavy rain strong winds or
light snow each will have a unique
effect on different elements of players
ghost hunts
the last bit of new content being added
for halloween is a brand new nightmare
level difficulty designed to provide an
extra challenge for seasoned ghost
hunters this new difficulty level comes
on top of a broader overhaul of the
game's existing three difficulty levels
which were designed to make the game
more enjoyable for players at any skill
level other than the new additions a
number of big tweaks and fixes have been
made to the game's existing features and
you can check out the full patch notes
on gamespot.com
if you've taken a little break from far
cry 6 you might see an email soon
pressuring you to come back screenshots
shared on twitter show a message from
the game's villain anton castillo
prodding out the players for only
playing a few hours of the game it even
looked like players were getting emails
whether they played 3 hours or a
thousand with various messaging to fit
if you've played far cry 6 have you seen
these messages if so how many hours do
you have in the game let us know in the
comments and make sure you leave a like
and subscribe so you never miss your
gamespot news updates
[Music]
you